[Musique]
votre attention s'il vous plaît
nous avons reçu devient triste nouvelle
du shérif du comté d'evergreen
reisinger a été retrouvé ce matin et sa
mort a été confirmée
[Musique]
mon choix c'est de découvrir des actus
et l'office nous nommer trop populiste
nous découvrons ce qui s'est passé
quelqu'un qu'on connaît
j'aurais pu le faire sérieux si tu t'es
lire tu crois bright soit le quart a
fait du mal à beaucoup de gens mais
celle qui l'avait le plus blessé c'était
jessica déficit quelqu'un a tiré sur
price
elle leur a refourgué qu'est ce que tu
m'as balancé
non je te cherche un pti
thibault comptes d'accor glay été testée
bryce ouais je souhaitais pas sa mort
je sais que bryce a fait du mal est ce
que tu sais quoi que ce soit
jusqu'à ce que je tombe là dessus les
johnson
j'ai absolument rien fait mais la police
a l'air sûr que si
je suis là si jamais tu as besoin que je
te couvre
et toi tu étais au soir là pas un alibi
pour chaque minute
si tu veux laver ton ombre prêtre
commence par regarder sont antoine
[Musique]
je sais que j'aurais dû en parler
je dois le faire maintenant
et aujourd'hui le monde se porte
nettement mieux sans lui
qu'est ce que tu as fait ensuite
[Musique]